we're about to watch tlc show body
bazaar again don't love the title i've
said that time and time again with many
of these shows but i think there's a lot
to learn not only from a medical
standpoint but from a compassion and
empathy standpoint let's check it out
to claudio vieira de oliveira a 37 year
old with a curious condition
wow there's some kind of contractures
likely to be congenital but could be
traumatic
no one has ever been able to explain the
reason i was born with this disability
obviously you could see that there's
deformities throughout the body hands
feet the spinal cord there's some
involvement and it's likely something to
do with the musculoskeletal system
because otherwise it looks like he's
functional he's cognitively there he's
telling a story his spinal column is so
severely twisted that his head rests
facing backwards
when i was born
the doctor said i wouldn't leave longer
than 24 hours
the doctor was wrong claudio survived
happily and pain-free his parents having
lost faith in doctors opinions never
brought him back to the hospital wow
risky obviously given the nature of this
condition it's possible that in the area
where this person lives they might not
have medical care where they would have
these answers even they would need
someone very sub-sub-specialized for
condition that's this this rare the fact
that he's not in pain is really
incredible because it looks like there's
a lot of muscular imbalance that would
likely result of this maybe even nerve
impingements where there's pressure on
the nerve and you're going to start
getting abnormal sensations down the
body i have never contemplated giving up
maybe this strength
comes from my family
and friends support having a strong
support system especially one from a
family goes such a long way knowing that
there's people who care for you as a
youngster claudio was determined to get
an education it's interesting looking at
someone who obviously had to face a lot
of challenges to use equipment that is
not made for him it's not easily
accessible and yet he's finding a way to
persevere through it so it's important
to show how adaptable the human mind can
be when it is faced with a challenge the
hard work paid off today claudio is an
accountant wow i am someone who managed
to adapt to my body
i don't see myself as being different
from a normal person this is his
perspective and we validate this
perspective we should validate this
perspective and at the same time if
another individual sees him and views
him as different but is still very
encouraging it's very fair to him kind
that is also acceptable we as humans
need to have a wide variety of emotions
and a wide variety of opinions in terms
of how we interact with the world now a
person who experiences a congenital
situation like his may look at it and
say i wish i could change certain things
about my body and get medical care in
order to improve certain aspects of
their lives that is totally reasonable
as well he has had pain in his legs from
shuffling across the hard floor see
that's why i found it weird when in the
beginning they said that he wasn't
experiencing pain just biomechanically
the way that he moves around in his
position you could see that there's
going to be muscular strain nerve strain
ligamentous strain and skin breakdown
from constantly putting pressure on
certain areas of his body when i got
shoes my life became much easier
which makes an afternoon outing even
more comfortable it's great to see his
family be around him and other children
especially because it teaches them from
a young age that humans are different we
come in all shapes and sizes and there
is no perfectly normal human we're all
different dr angelina acosta a medical
geneticist has become fascinated by
claudio's case and wants to examine him
in person
it's really rare to see a page with all
these limitations surviving yeah because
there's cardiopulmonary compromise when
there's such severe deformities of the
spine you need to really get a good
sense of what the anatomy is like the
circulation in the body because remember
like we have balance center in our ears
that is largely dependent on gravity but
when your head is constantly in an
upside down orientation it has to adapt
so it's going to be interesting to
investigate how that's happening what
could be improved what could be learned
from this this is only obviously if he
wants to do that claudio agrees to see
the doctor the thought of surgery scares
me because i don't know what the result
will be if i had surgery
would it be the same claudio the city of
claudia or would that be worse that's a
important question to ask for any
surgery that is essentially trying to
figure out is medical intervention a
necessary and do the benefits outweigh
the risks she's eager to know what
caused his deformities and sends him for
x-rays that's not going to answer the
question more so just show the bones
within the body genetic testing is
probably the way to figure that out a
lot of genetic conditions don't
necessarily have to occur because you
inherited them sometimes there could be
spontaneous abnormalities in genes that
can cause birth defects or situations to
even arise in adulthood claudio is
surprisingly healthy and as for any
medical intervention dr acosta believes
it wouldn't be worth it interventions
come from a need and b benefit with
minimizing risk but no intervention zero
unless they don't work have no risks we
can say that he has
after a repose
multiplex congenital
deposition contractures
fixes
[Music]
any procedure that would need to happen
surgery-wise would require multiple
surgeons to be available at the same
time you're going to need a lot of
specials because there's a lot of parts
of the body involved here even like a
cardiothoracic surgeon would probably be
wise it can be a neurological problem
can be a muscle problem so it's really
necessary to continue the investigation
to try to confirm the diagnosis to
confirm the diagnosis is really for case
report purposes for research to
understand it to be able to help others
in the future if possible it's very
unlikely that by studying this
continuously they're going to be able to
offer some kind of recommendation that
he doesn't already have
23 year old tom stanford has been
training for years to be a world-class
cyclist cycling is hard i got a new bike
i haven't ridden it a lot because i get
tired real easy
he suffers from a mystery condition that
no one's ever been able to figure out
he's very thin tom's strange illness has
left his body unable to store fat under
his skin he only has 40 percent of an
average man's muscle tissue and is
partially deaf again likely to be
congenital because it has developed this
way he didn't happen in adulthood
protein disorder is up there some kind
of coding protein could have a mutation
in it tom seemed like a normal baby at
birth and had a happy childhood
he already had a unique facial structure
so maybe he was predisposed to this
condition by the time he was a teenager
his body had completely stopped
metabolizing fat leading to drastic
weight loss he's six foot three and
weighs only 133 pounds wow just for a
comparison sake i'm six for 395 pounds
right now a lot of people will forget
the fact that fat is an important
macronutrient and we could use it for
energy and we need it to make certain
hormones it's the over consumption
specifically of unhealthy fats that is
one of the biggest drivers of heart
disease and death now he wants to go
further and compete in the paralympics
that's got to be hard because if you
can't metabolize and digest fat you have
a significant disadvantage of energy
storage and breakdown
because tom's medical condition is
undiagnosed the sports governing body
doesn't know how to classify him for
competition when we look at the icd-10
classification the international
classification of diseases 10 we have
coding for things and you can do genetic
disorder unspecified i'm sure there's a
code for that icd-10 genetic disorder
unspecified
look at that z 15.89 genetic
susceptibility to other disease that
would be a code that would probably get
him into the special olympics when i
first met tom it was kind of a bit odd
to see him for the first time in real
life and that's okay to say right if
something is unusual it's okay to say
something unusual and be curious and
kind at the same time about it
pretending that something that is
unusual
just to ease your own discomfort may not
be ideal for that even person because
they want to be honest and
straightforward about what's going on
with them or their bodies they may take
that as a sign of that you're
blocking because you're feeling shame or
some kind of negative emotion to their
appearance
because i don't store fat it remains in
the bloodstream so because of this i
have type 2 diabetes i'm struggling to
understand exactly what his condition is
because if he has an issue absorbing fat
then it wouldn't enter the blood but it
is entering the blood so he's having
trouble processing the fat once it's
already in the blood basically driving
it into the cells for energy or
converting it to different cholesterols
and triglycerides etc there's a new
technology called next generation
sequencing which allows scientists to
screen the whole genome this is 30 000
genes and it's equivalent to looking for
a single spelling mistake amongst a
library full of 30 000 books finally tom
has a diagnosis mandibular dysplasia
with deafness and projeroid features mdp
syndrome i mean i would like to know
more about the diagnosis because i mean
you know just because we've labeled
something based on the appearance and
the other symptoms and prognosis that
he's experiencing do we know yet the
gene that is involved with this this is
probably one of those cases where the
patient is by far a bigger expert in
their condition than any doctor they
would go see
huang who suffers from a disorder called
neurofibromatosis
is plagued with the largest facial tumor
the world has ever seen
neurofibromatosis there's multiple types
i believe it's a genetic condition where
there's little tumors that can form on
the skin
on neurological structures on your body
think the eyes the brain the spinal cord
by the time he was 31 huang's facial
tumor weighed over 50 pounds wow the
weight of the tumor damaged his spine
and torso and he only reached four feet
tall that's also got to be uncomfortable
that that amount of pressure constantly
tugging at the elastacity of your skin
pulling the eyes maybe not being able to
close your eye fully which can cause
tearing dryness of the eye the chinese
government offered to cover the expense
of major facial surgery
i had never seen a tumor as big as
swangs in my career on a human body
i was completely overwhelmed
a lot of imaging has to take place here
to see what anatomical structures are in
the masses like is it just tumor
material is it blood vessels is it
nerves
this was the most complicated case in
the world
there were no cases to use as a
reference i'm surprised they wouldn't
reach out to other worldwide leaders at
this point there's a lot of
collaboration that happens amongst
doctors in rare cases where it's
beneficial not only for the patient but
also for the doctors to get this
experience to be able to treat other
patients in their home countries
it's taken a team of china's best
doctors over seven years and four
pioneering operations to remove more
than 45 pounds of tissue from huang's
tumor 45 pounds that's a lot he's got a
face he can live with yeah a face and a
life like it takes a toll carrying that
much excess weight on your face you
can't enjoy daily activities and quality
of life begins to suffer outside of
social living just functional
22 year old amanda grice has a rare and
embarrassing problem for 12 years she's
been living in a permanent state of
sexual arousal oh wow i lost count
honestly of how many times a day i have
orgasms i'd have 50 orgasms and well
into the day it would be well over a
hundred by that evening this type of
persistent sexual arousal syndrome was
documented in my video with dr rima
malik where we talked about it but it's
a very complex situation because a lot
of things have to be taken into
consideration not just physical health
but psychological as well 50 orgasms a
day might sound like pure pleasure but
it's making amanda's life a living hell
no it's not pure pleasure anything that
falls outside of a balance can become
quite problematic a lot of people hate
pain and they say i wish i could never
feel pain that would be very problematic
the reason you know to take your hand
off a hot stove is because you feel pain
so it's a protective mechanism the
reason why you your foot goes numb and
you get pins and needles it's
uncomfortable and you know to move it is
because of pain had you not known that
your foot can die so like all of these
signals that can be problematic if
experienced to a high degree also need
to be experienced to some degree to get
the benefits of them amanda is desperate
for help but so far the medical
community has let her down at every turn
most of them are very dismissive about
it a lot of doctors don't have knowledge
of this disorder dismissal very
disappointing that the medical community
doesn't help or doesn't even want to
help not knowing i could see why that
could happen it's hard unless you're a
specialist to know about this condition
not know about its presence but know
what to do and what to try what's
interesting to me is there's all sorts
of nerve ablation therapies that we do
where basically like let's say one of
your cutaneous nerves across your
abdomen that come from your ribs
intercostals is constantly lighting up
you're having pain in that nerve and we
try all sorts of treatments you could do
like a nerve ablation where you
essentially shut that nerve down in her
case i wonder if that's possible as well
or would there be other consequences to
it i again would need a sub sub sub
specialist help me answer that question
hi amanda nice to meet you have a seat
hi how are you
dr eckenberg is a pioneer in
understanding and treating persistent
genital arousal syndrome i want to know
how you become a pioneer in that i just
need the answer to that question genuine
curiosity on my part and believes that
pgad is largely misunderstood as a
sexual disorder when in fact it's more a
function of chronic pain to treat that
disorder he'll inject her bladder with
medications to relax the muscles and
ease the pain 24 hours later she's
already feeling the benefits amanda will
continue to have regular bladder
injections which will numb her orgasms
so she will only experience a few a day
is it like just a lidocaine type
medicine where it's a numbing agent or
is it a muscular relaxing agent or even
a muscle paralyzing agent that would be
a botox injection into the bladder would
probably be too much then again not a
specialist i need more info
doctors continually blame this patient's
symptoms on his weight i thought
otherwise so we were able to help them
click here to check out that entire
story and as always stay happy and
healthy
[Music]